what's the next category gentleman let's
find out let us find out yes
sorry dory oh man there's so many great
stories that we've told
give me some more wine buddy all right
i'll hit you all right i can't even
remember half the stories we tell
i mean it's just we all just come to the
table with some great stories what can i
say
that's why you guys watch the episodes
right i know i
i think it's the stories it was the
stories that first distinguished trash
taste from like
an anime podcast and everyone was just
like wait we don't give a [ __ ] about
them talking about anime
just give us more stories give us more
stories my parents sometimes uh
message me like connor you you got that
wrong what the one detail wrong
yeah yeah i guess it doesn't matter i
get that all the time yeah yeah it
doesn't matter i get that from my
parents as well
they always remember differently yeah
yeah but let's look at the nominees for
this one
yeah all right so
just play it just please play the clip
this is so much so good i don't want
context
that was the point where we basically
him and i
we found out that we found out from each
other that we're into those kinds of
shows
we're just into each other yeah like it
keeps getting worse and worse
though yeah i didn't even do that on
purpose i was like how do i how do i
structure the story
like because i i was like i was i
remember like losing it when you were
telling the story because i was like
there's no way he is not doing this on
purpose
right and it just kept getting worse and
worse and if it was not like the
if if it wasn't the award for best out
of context moment
yeah this was just the best out of
context like story
story like everything like this
encapsulates everything about out of
context
it's [ __ ] amazing and that that one
little clip doesn't do this entire story
justice go watch the full clip on the
highlights
channel but uh what's the next one huge
dong during his job
my career is on the line here i just
want to get a job what he
what could you possibly be laughing at
and then i look at what i drawn
i've drawn a penis i love that clip that
clip is so good that's such a good story
oh my gosh
i still like i remember telling that
story and my parents didn't know that
that happened during my job
so they found out that that was the
reason i got rejected from my first job
interview
from watching trash taste oh yeah a very
stern text from your mom followed
that's how you keep the fans coming you
know you gotta get a tease in with them
uh and then this one just inspired an
entire special didn't you yeah
play the clip play the clip how i ended
up in playing professional chess was
weird to begin with because i never
like played it much i just liked video
games a lot yeah i mean
it was it was a very long story and i i
think this was less of like a funny
story more of just like
this is like a character development
stuff yeah right yeah that was like one
of the clips i feel that people like
whoa what the [ __ ]
yeah i was like what the [ __ ] yeah
because i remember you telling that
story to me beforehand and i was just
like
you've got to tell this somewhere yeah
that's an amazing [ __ ] story
i've got to tell you and i'm glad that
people really enjoyed it like i remember
when that clip came out or the episode
came out people like whoa
they really went round with them i mean
you know and then chess.com hit us up
after that yeah yeah yeah and then
entitled
the chess tournament
this is such a great story i love this
out of so many poop stories that
we've told on this podcast i think this
is probably my favorite poop so
disgusting
getting that [ __ ] putting it in a
halloween a pumpkin sorry
and throwing the pumpkin at one of my
friend's windows
and it just exploded that's one of those
stories where it's like
this story would have been 100 times
funny if you were there yeah yeah
but it's still hilarious it's hilarious
it's like disgusting in the moment yeah
like the moment you get to tell it the
first time yeah it's just hilarious
how [ __ ] absurd this thing is and how
funny it is and also
that both my poor mate who was like two
windows over for me
who had to clean that [ __ ] up because
the school said they would take them a
week to get there right
it takes all the week to get to coming
out and clean it and he was like i can't
leave [ __ ] on my window for a week
this is so funny it's such a good story
and then uh oh yeah and then this is
another
story the second character development
story i guess normally
when you want to give your family like
good karma
everyone in my family has been a monk
like twice in their life
everyone in my family what happened
there
yeah wait check the suit check the suit
oh good okay i haven't
yeah i mean this was i guess this is the
first time i've ever talked about being
a monk
in public despite how long i've been on
the internet and even like
i know i remember because even for the
longest time even for like my closest
friends
nobody knew i was a monk yeah and i
can't remember who you told me this
story yeah yeah
you had to like drag it out of me yeah
because i was like
what what
because i i don't know anyone around me
who used to be a monk that's [ __ ]
cool
yeah yeah i love how at this rate my
character development isn't me literally
coming out to my friend
that is your character that's my
character he was just like i was a
degenerate i still am a degenerate but i
gotta always will be
that i got very homoerotic with my
friend while watching kisses
and then what's the last clip there i
can't see the last one
oh the most awkward elevator ride ever
oh yeah this is my story this is a good
one
for the action alone yeah door opens and
this like black guy walks in he walks in
really quietly door closes
starts going down and then he just goes
oh yeah everybody shuts up when the
edward walks in
i can just i can only just fathom oh you
can't make that [ __ ] up
what i love about the story is like how
i can relate to that story even though i
wasn't there
yeah because i can exactly see that
moment happening like
that could have happened to any one of
us to this day that is still the
scariest experience i had in america
like hands down but for like a different
reason yeah oh my god like honestly
what's gonna win i have no i i i i i
can't pick one
because like it's a nice mixture right
because it's a mixture of like really
hilarious moments versus like really
kind of wholesome deep moments yeah
i think that maybe the monk one will win
maybe
i feel like that's the most iconic i
don't know i'm thinking either the monk
one or the chess pro one i mean
in terms of like the stories people
remember the monk one and the chess when
i feel stand out because that's like
played a huge part in like our
characters true true true
um but i mean i i feel like i feel like
there were even more stories than this
that we didn't get to put in our
nominations oh absolutely because there
were like there was so
there's been so many good stories that
i've told and you guys have told over
the years that i don't even remember all
of them right now
so i can't pick one honestly this is
[ __ ] difficult
oh i'm glad i didn't have to pick
because the view is picked
and the best story of the year goes
to connor becoming a chessboard
i mean look it inspired an entire
special yeah it makes lots
this is deep in the trash taste yeah all
right it is like this
this one probably has one of the most
effects on like
the trash taste law and [ __ ]
character development because i feel
like what is this [ __ ] screen crap
because i i even feel like this was the
first big story told on this podcast i
think so
yeah yeah i i how much did i win by
though
30 oh
actual penis hey guys here's the length
of my dick
wow fair enough fair enough